and today I'm going to talk about
sequencing and I want to start by just
sort of illustrating an example of how
knowing the DNA sequence can be helpful
so you remember in last lecture we
talked about how one might identify a
gene through functional complementation
and this process involved making a DNA
library that different fragments of DNA
cloned into different plasmids and and
then involved finding the needle in the
haystack where you're you find the gene
that can rescue a defect in a mutant
that you have so if this line that I'm
drawing here is genomic DNA and it could
be genomic DNA from let's say a proto
truth for Lou to the leucine to gene so
this is from a proto troph then you
could cut up the the DNA with eco r1 and
if there's not a restriction site in
this loo to gene you get a fragment that
contains the Lu to gene and then you
could clone this into some type of
plasmid that replicates in the organism
that you're introducing and propagating
it in and so that would allow you to
then test whether or not this piece of
DNA that you have complements allude to
auxotrophs
okay now one thing I want to point out
is that because these eco r1 sites these
sticky ends they recognized they
recognized they would recognize this eco
r1 and or this eco R at one end you can
imagine that this gene if the gene reads
this
this way it could insert this way into
the plasmid or it could insert in the
opposite direction so it could be
inverted okay so this would have some
sort of origin of replication and some
type of selectable marker but if you
have the same restriction site right it
can insert one way or the opposite way
that's just one thing I wanted to point
out okay now let's say let's say rather
than leucine you are interested in
cyclin dependent kinase and you had a
mutant in cdk and you had this sequence
of your yeast cdk gene well rather than
having to dig through a whole library of
pieces of DNA for the cdk dean gene and
basically you're sort of fishing for
that needle in the haystack if you knew
the sequence of the human genome you'd
be able to identify similar genes by
sequence homology and you could then
take a more direct approach where you
take let's say you have a piece of human
DNA now double-stranded DNA and it has
the cdk gene you could take human DNA
with the cdk gene and you have unique
sequence around the cdk gene which would
allow you to denature this DNA and if
you denature the DNA you'd get two
single strands of DNA and you could then
design primers that recognize unique
sequences flanking the cdk gene so you
can imagine you'd have a primer here and
a primer here and then you could use PCR
to amplify specifically the cdk gene
from it could be the genome or from some
library and then you get this fragment
here which includes CDK
okay so knowing the sequence of the
genome would allow you to more rapidly
go from maybe a gene that you've
identified as being important in one
organism and find the human equivalent
that might have be doing something
similar in humans okay
so this step here is basically PCR okay
and let's say the cdk gene had
restriction sites let's see we'll use
will say restriction site k and a here
then if you have these restriction sites
in your fragment of DNA you can then
digest or cut that piece of DNA with
these restriction endonucleases and then
you'd get a fragment of cdk
that has K and a sticky ends we'll
pretend that both of these have sticky
ends and now you have unique sticky ends
between K and a and you might have a
vector that also has these two sites and
you could digest this vector with these
two enzymes and that would allow you to
insert the specific gene in this plasmid
and if you have two unique sites because
K only recognizes K here and a only
recognizes a then it will like a t' in
but you can do it with a specific
orientation because you have two
different restriction sites okay so I
hope you all see sort of how how it's
different with one restriction site
versus two okay
all right now let's say you want to do
something more complicated than this
okay
let's say rather than just identifying
the gene that's involved in cell
division let's say you want to engineer
a new gene in order to determine let's
say where this particular protein CDK
localizes in the cell
okay so we have cdk which could be from
yeast or human it doesn't matter and you
want to engineer a new protein if you
would basically that you can see that
you can see okay so remember professor
Imperiali
introduced green fluorescent protein
earlier in the year and this green
fluorescent protein is from a gene from
jellyfish so now we could using what
I've told you reconstruct or engineer a
gene that has DNA from three different
organisms in order to make a cdk a
variant that we are able to see in the
cell so remember green fluorescent
protein is like Amalek it's like a
beacon if it's attached to a protein if
you shine blue light on it it emits
green light and so you can use a
fluorescent microscope in order to see
it okay in this case let's say there's
also another restriction site here R and
let's say you have a fragment of GFP
that has two restriction sites a and are
you could then cut this fragment and
this fragment with these restriction
enzymes a and R and you could insert GFP
at the c-terminus of the cdk gene okay
so you could go and have a gene that has
cdk GFP inserted inside a bacterial
vector okay now which one of these sort
of Junction sites do you think would be
most sensitive in doing this type of
experiment
so there are three Junction sites right
there's this one this one in this one
which is the one you're probably gonna
put the most thought into when you're
doing this experiment yes miles the
exact miles is exactly right this one's
going to be important right and why did
you choose that site and if you're
trying to make a fusion protein what's
going to be an important sort of quality
of this you have a point
[Music]
excellent job so Malik just pointed out
two really important things right to
make this a fusion protein right you
have two different open reading frames
these two open reading frames have to be
in frame with each other okay so this
Junction here has to be in frame where
GFP is in frame with cdk meaning that
you're reading sort of the same sort of
triplet codons for GFP they're in the
same frame as cdk also you want to make
sure there's no stop codon here is if
you had a stop codon here you're just
gonna make a cdk protein and then it's
gonna stop and then you won't have it
fused to gfp okay and you guys will work
through more of these and the homework
so you'll be able to get a sense of it
okay so now for the remainder of this
lecture and also for Monday's lecture I
want to go through a problem with you
which is basically if you have a given
disease that's heritable how might you
go from sort of knowing that that
disease is heritable to finding out what
gene is responsible for that given
disease okay and this is going to
involve thinking about different levels
of resolution in terms of maps so the
highest resolution map you can have for
a genome is the sequence you can have
the full nucleotide sequence of a genome
okay and that's the highest possible
resolution because you have single
nucleotide resolution as to what every
single base pair is okay but that's like
you know that's like knowing like your
apartment number and your street number
and basically knowing everything right
but starting out you might want to know
like what continent it's on or what what
country is it in okay and so you first
have to sort of
the possible locations for a given
disease gene and that will first involve
establishing what chromosome and what
region of a chromosome a given disease
allele is linked to okay and that's
known as its that involves making
essentially a linkage map where you
establish where a disease gene is
located based on its linkage to known
markers that are present in the genome
okay now this is going to require that
you remember back we week or two weeks
ago to when we talked about linkage and
recombination and you'll recall that we
were looking at the linkage between
genes and flies and genes and yeast
right one difference between that type
of linkage mapping and human linkage
mapping is we don't have really clear
traits that are defined by single genes
right you can't just take hair color and
map like the hair color gene to link it
to a disease gene okay because hair
color is determined by many many
different genes okay so in fruit flies
you can take white eyes and see if it's
connected with yellow body color because
both of those are determined by single
genes so we need something other than
just having sort of phenotypic traits
that we can track we need what are known
as molecular markers to be able to
perform linkage mapping okay and so what
would we need in these molecular markers
well if we just think about if we wanted
to determine the linkage between the a
and B genes right and if you did this
cross would you be able to determine
linkage
giorgia you made a motion that was
correct tell me why why did you shake
your head no yeah they'd all be
heterozygous right you can't because
this individual has the same allele on
both chromosomes you're not going to be
able to differentiate one chromosome
from the other okay and so the point I
want to make is that in order to see
linkage what you need is variation okay
so we need to have variation and another
term for genetic variation is
polymorphism okay so we need
polymorphism or genetic variation
between these molecular markers we also
need genetic variation in the disease
but we have that right we don't we have
individuals that are affected by a
disease and individuals that are not
affected by a disease so we have
variation and alleles there but we in
order to map it with two Amalek with a
molecular marker to map linkage to a
molecular marker you also need variation
here right so the problem with this
cross is here you need to have a
heterozygote right there needs to be
individual there needs to be variation
in this individual where both of these
alleles are heterozygous okay so now I
want to talk about some of these
molecular markers that we can use and
how they vary between individuals and
between chromosomes okay
now this is going to be maybe the lowest
resolution map but I'm talking about
sort of this linkage map here and you
can see highlighted at the bottom here
are various types of polymorphisms that
we can use to link given
zees allele to a specific chromosome and
a specific place on a chromosome okay so
I'll start with the first one which is a
say a simple sequence repeat it goes by
many names but I will stick with what's
on the slide so a simple sequence repeat
is also known as a microsatellite so you
might see that term floating around if
you're reading about this and what a
what a simple sequence repeat is is as
the name implies it's a simple sequence
like it could be a dinucleotide like CA
and it's just a dinucleotide that's
repeated over and over again okay so you
might have on a chromosome you might
have a unique sequence which I'll just
draw as a line and then you could have a
see a dinucleotide that's repeated some
number of times N and then that's
followed by another unique sequence okay
and that's what's present image so that
would be one strand and then in the
opposite strand you'd have unique
sequence the complement of C a which is
G T and then again unique sequence okay
and so there's variation in the number
of repeats of the CA and so there's
polymorphism so we can use this to
establish linkage between this marker
and a phenotype like a disease phenotype
okay so how might you detect the number
of repeats that are present here anyone
have an idea of a tool that we've
discussed that could be used here so one
hint that I gave you is that the
sequence here is unique and the sequence
here is unique so is there a way we can
leverage that unique sequence to
determine whether there's a difference
in the number of repeats
what technique we discussed that
involves some component of the technique
recognizing a unique sequence yeah
Natalie
well CRISPR casts nine is a possibility
Jeremy did you have an idea PCR so I
mean it's true you could you could get
it to recognize that but then you have
to detect it somehow so what's more
commonly used is PCR those are both good
ideas but using PCR you could design a
primer here and a primer here and you
could amplify this repeat sequence and
the number of repeats would determine
the size of your PCR fragment okay so if
you did PCR then you get a PCR fragment
that has the primers on each end but
then has this certain size based on the
number of repeats okay so in that case
we need some sort of tool that enables
us to determine the size of a particular
DNA fragment and so I'm gonna just
introduce to you one such tool which is
gel electrophoresis and gel
electrophoresis involves taking DNA that
you've generated by either PCR or by
cutting up DNA with the restriction
enzyme and loading it in the well on in
a gel that has agarose maybe it's
composed of agarose it could be composed
of poly acrylamide and then because DNA
is negatively charged the backbone if
you run a current through it such that
the positive electrode is at the bottom
then the DNA is going to snake through
this gel okay now we'll do a quick
demonstration if you two could come up I
need one volunteer Ori find ten of your
friends and bring them down
all right that's that's that's that's
probably good yeah
all right Hanna won't you you guys have
to link up okay
stay over here we'll start at this end
this is the negative electrode over here
okay the positive electrode is going to
be down there and Jackie is gonna be our
single nucleotide
okay you guys link link like yeah you
know you don't have to dosey doe or
anything like that but uh all right now
what I want you guys to do is I want you
to slalom through these cones like it's
a gross gel so that you're going towards
the other side okay and I'm going to
turn on the current now so go
all right stop all right see how the
shorter DNA fragment is able to more
easily navigate through the cones and
get farther okay okay so then you know
this is it was somewhat rigged I know
but I just needed some way to make sure
you always remember that the shorter
nucleotide or the shorter fragment is
going to migrate faster okay you guys
can go back up thank you for your
participation let's give them a round of
applause all right so what you just saw
is that the longer DNA fragments right
they're going to be more inhibited by
moving through the gel and so they're
gonna move slower and thus not move as
far in the gel whereas the small
fragments are going to move much faster
because they're able to sort of maneuver
their way through this gel much more
quickly so there's gonna be an inverse
proportionality between the size of the
DNA chain and its rate of movement okay
where you're always gonna see the
shorter DNA fragment moving faster okay
so what one of these gels actually looks
like is shown here
so this is a DNA gel this agarose and
DNA has been run in these different
samples and what you're seeing is this
gel is subsequently stained with a dye
like a thin iam bromide which allows you
to visualize the individual DNA
fragments and so a band on this gel
indicates a whole bunch of DNA fragments
that are all roughly the same length
okay so you essentially you can measure
DNA length using this technique what's
over here at the end of the gel this is
probably some sort of DNA ladder where
you have DNA fragments of known length
that you can use to calibrate the length
of these bands over here okay so this is
how you measure DNA length and we're
going to use it over and over again as
we talk about DNA and sequencing so now
let's think about how this is going to
help us
establish linkage between a particular
marker in the genome and a genetic
disease okay so if we think about these
microsatellite repeats right I told you
they're polymorphic they exhibit a lot
of variation in size and so here's an
example showing you a female who has two
intermediate sized microsatellites and
if you look at this the if you did PCR
and measured the size of these you get
two different bands because there are
two different alleles of different
lengths here okay so you can see this
individual has two intermediate length
repeats and this person has had children
with an individual that has a short and
a long microsatellite and you can see
that on the gel here okay now this
female is affected by some disease and
these two individuals have children and
you can see that a number of those
children are affected by the disease
so what mode of inheritance does this
look like if you had your choice between
autosomal recessive autosomal dominant
sex link dominance x-linked recessive
which what mode of inheritance is this
looking like oh Carmen
autosomal recessive why why do you go
with recessive so yeah go ahead
seems like
fathers
that's possible that's that's definitely
that's exactly the logic I want to see
is there another possibility yeah Jeremy
it could also be autosomal dominant okay
so you're right you're right if this was
not a rare disease than that that male
could be a carrier and could be passing
it on to half the children so that's
good you'd you'd essentially need more
information to differentiate between
autosomal recessive and autosomal
dominant for the purposes of this we're
gonna go with dominant autosomal
dominant and what you see is that you
want to look at the affected individuals
and see if the disease phenotype is
linked or connected with one of these
microsatellite alleles okay so if we
look at you know we basically PCR DNA
from all these individuals and if you
look at who's affected each one of the
individuals has this M double prime band
and none of the unaffected individuals
has it okay so you know this obviously
it would be better to have more
pedigrees and more data to really
establish significance between this
linkage but this is just a simple
example showing what you could possibly
see if you have one of these molecular
markers linked to a particular disease
allele okay so that kind of establishes
the principle now let's think about what
are some other molecular markers that
are possible so another type of marker
and this is one that's the most common
one if I go here so here you see here's
a linkage map here and you see most of
these bands are green and the green
markers here are what are known as
single nucleotide polymorphism Kali
morphisms or snips okay
so single nucleotide polymorphisms and
this is abbreviated snip okay and what a
single nucleotide polymorphism is is
it's a variation of a nucleotide at a
single position in the genome okay so
it's just a one base pair difference in
the in at a position so this variation
of single nucleotide at a given position
at a position in the genome okay and
because that's a pretty general
definition there are tons of these in
the genome okay now one thing to think
about is you could have a mutation in an
individual that creates a snip okay so
you could have a de novo formation of a
snip but if you have a snip and it gets
incorporated to the gametes of an
individual then that variant is going to
be passed on to the next generation okay
so this is something that could occur de
novo but it is also heritable and if
it's heritable then you can use it you
can follow it and use it to determine if
a given variant is linked to a given
phenotype like a disease so to identify
a single nucleotide polymorphism it's
helpful to be able to sequence the DNA
and I'll talk about how we could do that
in just a minute but before I go on I
just want to point out a subclass of
snips that can be visualized without
sequencing and these are called
restriction fragment length
polymorphisms so restriction fragment so
it's going to involve some type of
restriction enzyme digest
length polymorphism it's a long word but
it's abbreviated rift lip okay and what
this is is it's a variation of a single
nucleotide but this is a subclass of
snip because this is when the variation
occurs any restriction site for a
restriction enzyme okay so if you
remember your good friend eco r1 eco r1
recognizes the nucleotide sequence
g-a-a-t-t-c and eco r1 only cleaves DNA
sequence that has g-a-a-t-t-c okay so if
there was a single variation there's a
single nucleotide variation in the
sequence such that it's now GA t t t c
or something like that that destroys the
eco r1 site and so eco r1 will no longer
be able to recognize this site in the
genome and cut it okay so you could
imagine that if you had one individual
in the genome having three equal r1
sites if you digest this region you'd
get two fragments but if you destroyed
the one in the middle then if you
digested this piece of DNA then you'd
only get one fragment okay and that's
something because it results in
different sizes of fragments that's
something you can see just by doing DNA
electrophoresis and maybe you would use
some method to detect this specific
region so that you're not looking at all
the DNA in the genome but you're
establishing linkage to this specific
area okay you could use PCR right you
can have PCR primers here and here and
you could then cut with eco r1 in one
case you'd get two fragments in this
case you get two fragments in this case
if you amplified this region of the
genome and cut with eco r1 you'd only
get one fragment
okay so you'd be able to differentiate
between those possibilities yes
Malik what's up oh you're saying what
causes it to stop
that's a great question Malik yeah so
initially it's not gonna stop that's
absolutely right but because every step
each time you replicate it's then primed
with another primer right so you'd
replicate something like this right
that's too long but then the reverse
primer would replicate like this and it
would stop okay
so if you go back to my slide from last
lecture you look through that and see if
it makes sense how it's ending because
if you do this 30 times you really will
enrich for a fragment that sort of stops
and ends at the two primers or begins
and ends at the two primers I should say
okay
good question thank you all right now
let's talk about DNA sequencing because
as I showed you obviously these snips
because they're so many of them are
probably the most useful of these
markers to narrow in on where your
disease gene is and to detect a snip we
need to have we need to be able to
sequence DNA so I'm gonna start with an
older method for DNA sequencing which
conceptually is very similar to how we
do DNA sequencing today and so it will
illustrate my point and then at the end
I'll sort I'll talk about how more
modern techniques distinct sequencing so
the technique I'm going to introduce to
you is called Sanger sequencing and
that's because it was a an individual it
was identified by an individual named
Fred Sanger and I'm going to just take a
very simple DNA sequence in order to
illustrate how Sanger sequencing works
so let's take a sequence that's really
simple this is very very simple right so
and then more sequence here so let's say
we want to determine the nucleotide
that's at every position of this DNA
fragment okay so one way we could maybe
conceptually think about doing this is
to try to let DNA polymerase tell us
we're given nucleotides are and if we're
gonna use DNA polymerase what are we
going to need to in order to facilitate
this process yes Rachel you're going to
need nucleotides definitely so we're
gonna need nucleotides what else to
start what are you going to need miles
you're gonna need a primer exactly good
job so we're gonna need a primer okay so
here's a primer and now we're gonna try
to get DNA polymerase to tell us
whenever there is a given nucleotide in
this DNA sequence okay and so think me
think with me let's say we were able to
get DNA polymerase to stop whenever
there was a certain nucleotide okay so
if we go through just a couple
nucleotides let's say at first we want
DNA polymerized DNA polymerase to stop
whenever there's an a okay so let's say
there was a possibility it would stop at
this a if it stopped at this a you
generate a fragment of this length but
if it read on through that a there's
another possibility that it would stop
at this a so we're kind of looking at
when these are stopping
and the final possibility is it goes on
and stops at this a okay so if this DNA
polymerase stopped only at A's you get
fragments that are these three discrete
lengths okay
now let's consider another possibility
so pink here is stopped at a and in blue
I'm gonna draw what would happen if it
stopped at T okay so they all start from
the same place if it stopped at T it
would just stop one nucleotide beyond
this a in this simple sequence okay so
in blue here this is stopped at T okay
but if it's if it's just a possibility
it stops and some of the polymerase is
could go beyond this T and go to the
next T and stop here and again this
would be one nucleotide length longer
than this pink one here and the final
one would I'll just draw it down here
would get out to this last T here okay
so what you see is if we could get DNA
polymerase to stop at these discrete
positions we'd get a different sized
fragments whether it was stopping it one
nucleotide versus the other nucleotide
okay you all see how this is resulting
in different fragment lengths yes Andrew
there's there are companies now you can
basically take nucleotides and
synthesize these primers chemically okay
I'm not using DNA polymerase in this
case you'd have to start with some
sequence that you know right so in most
sequencing technologies you take you
kind of make a DNA library where you
know the sequence of the vector and then
you'd use the vector sequence as a
primer to sequence into the unknown
sequence okay great question
good job all right so so what we need
now then is some sort of tool or ability
to stop DNA polymerase at when there's a
certain nucleotide base okay and to do
that we can use this type of molecule
here which is known as the dye deoxy
nucleotide remember for DNA polymer for
DNA polymerase to elongate a chain it
requires that the last base have a three
prime hydroxyl okay and so what this dye
dye oxy nucleoside triphosphate is is
it's a nucleoside triphosphate that
lacks a three prime hydroxyl okay here
I'll highlight that so you see this guy
you see both the high light H there's a
hydrogen there on the three prime carbon
rather than the normal hydroxyl group
okay so if this if this base gets
incorporated into a elongating chain
right Diamond DNA polymerase is not
going to be able to move on okay so this
method where you can add a certain dye
deoxy nucleoside triphosphate to stop
chain elongation is known as a chain
termination method so you're getting
turn chain termination and you're
getting this chain termination with a
specific dye deoxy nucleus
side triphosphate so these dyed
deoxynucleotide triphosphates well if
they get incorporated into the DNA are
going to halt the synthesis of that DNA
strand so if we take our example here
right this might be a reaction that has
dye deoxy thymidine triphosphate so if
we had tidy oxy thymidine triphosphate
in this sample and it's elongating then
when the polymerase reaches this point
there's a possibility that it will
incorporate the dye deoxy nucleotide
triphosphate and if this is a dye deoxy
nucleoside triphosphate then there will
note alone there won't be a three prime
hydroxyl and DNA polymerase will just be
like oh I can't go on okay because it's
not going to have a three prime hydroxyl
so it's not going to be able to continue
with the next nucleotide okay so this is
known as chain termination okay so let
me take you through an example here
alright so here's an example that you
have a slide of and there again there's
a there's a template strand which is the
top strand and this method requires that
you have a primer and what's often done
is you label the primer okay so the
first step is you have to denature your
DNA so you have to go from
double-stranded DNA to single-stranded
DNA and then you mix the double-stranded
DNA with first this labeled primer such
that the primer can anneal to the
single-stranded DNA you need DNA
polymerase as I've mentioned
and as I believe Rachel mentioned before
you need the building blocks of DNA so
you need the four deoxy nucleoside
triphosphates so you always have the
four die oxy nucleotide triphosphates
well what's special here is you're going
to spike several reactions with a
certain with one of the die deoxy
nucleoside triphosphates so you spike
the reaction with a tiny amount of one
of your die deoxy nucleoside
triphosphates okay so let's say you have
a reaction here and this this one here
has died deoxy adenosine triphosphate
then polymerase will elongate this
straight strand until there's a
thymidine on the template and then
there's a possibility that it will
incorporate this dye deoxy ntp and if it
does then you get chain termination and
you get a fragment of this length but
the other possibility because there is
still the deoxy form of the ntp present
is possible that it incorporates a
deoxyadenosine triphosphate there and
keeps going and then incorporates a dye
deoxy ATP later on where you have
another tea okay and so the polymerase
will essentially randomly stop at these
different thymidine residues where
depending on whether or not a dye deoxy
nucleoside triphosphate is incorporated
and that means for a given reaction one
in which you have dye deoxy ATP you get
a certain pattern of bands that we
represent the length of fragments where
you have in this case a thymine base
okay and then you do this for all four
bases where you have four reactions each
with a different base that's dye deoxy
okay so when you're adding these you're
gonna do four reactions one with dye
deoxy ATP
spiked in one with dye deoxy TTP one
with dye deoxy CTP and the last with dye
deoxy gtp and because the these
nucleotides are present in different
positions along the sequence you're
gonna get this distinct banding pattern
for each of these reactions but using
that banding pattern you can then read
off the sequence of DNA that's present
on the template strand okay so this is
how sequencing was done for many many
years these days it's been made cheaper
and faster and now what's often used is
next-generation sequencing and you know
one sort of the pain in the ass about
sequencing before is you'd use a lot of
radioactivity your primer would be
radioactive a do active so that you
could detect to these bands right now
everything's done using fluorescence
which makes it much nicer I think and so
in next-generation sequencing your
template DNA is attached to a solid
substrate such as its immobilized on
some type of substrate and then you add
each of the four nucleoside
triphosphates in this case they're
labeled with a dye such that each one is
a different color but the dye also
functions to prevent elongation such
that again it's this chain termination
when you incorporate one of these the
polymerase just can't run along the DNA
it incorporates one and then stops so if
you get your first nucleotide
incorporated it will incorporate one of
these four and it will be fluorescent at
a certain wavelength which you can see
using them using a device or microscope
and then what you then do is chemically
modify this base such that you remove
the dye and allow it to extend one more
base pair and so you go sort of or one
nucleotide at a time and you read out
the pattern of fluorescence that appears
and that gives you the sequence of DNA
on this molecule that stuck to your
substrate right you can do this in
parallel you can have tons many
different strands of DNA and you can be
reading out the sequence of each one of
these strands in parallel okay great any
questions about DNA sequencing okay very
good I will see you on Monday
have a great weekend
you